the containers on the hong kong express
ship are piled six high the vessel from
the hamburg shipping company hapag-lloyd
is headed for South America more than
13,000 20-foot containers are in the
hall and on the deck rashad vaughn bear
laps is in charge of ship management for
hapag-lloyd last year he decided to
purchase new ships which are almost as
big as the hong kong express but far
more efficient and their kid a date with
the latest energy-saving technology yeah
in this any clients need it we go into
the smallest detail these days every
generator every pump on the ship is
regulated according to need badal I'm
get past that means that if the ship is
going slowly doesn't need to pump a lot
of cooling water so we slow down the
pumps and use less energy energy on a
toy and I mean naturally he is in the
heavy [ __ ] and you soon less
electricity and less fuel the container
shipping business has very thin profit
margins so saving fuel is vital so
important that a new ship costing
hundreds of millions pays for itself
within a few years the new ships being
built for hapag-lloyd also have a larger
container capacity they're destined to
connect Europe and the west coast of
South America they'll travel through the
Panama Canal which has recently been
widened and deepened shut meeting iron
pan luck chef Andi max instead of using
the old man max chips which carry a
maximum of five thousand standard
containers we can now travel through
with a ship that carries up to 13,000 of
them and Johan decide yeah that's why we
ordered the new ships for this route you
don't get these mega ships on the
charger market so we have to order them
as a missing sustaining Vince's he hop
LaPoint carrying twice as many
containers on one ship lowers the cost
per container and the new wider panama
canal will be able to keep up with the
growing demand says
bear laps that's why he decided to
purchase the ship's charger companies
are often not flexible enough saba7
loosen all provided dog charger ships
always have to be there where people
need them so you have to hire them there
too secondly if you use charter ships
there's another party in play and they
have to make a profit to recording the
new ships are intended to last at least
25 years and help hapag-lloyd to
continue to lead the market for shipping
between Europe and Latin America